[Musique]
une fois de plus tous unis derrière une
seule volonté rendre hommage aux
victimes et dire non à la barbarie avec
pour unité le drapeau bleu blanc rouge
et je suis charlie un rassemblement
d'élus et de citoyens
je pense que le messager blessure est
très très très important c'est l'avenir
de notre pays quelque part qui se joue
depuis quelques heures et vous dire
écoutez c'est aussi un représentant de
la république de porter ces messages ce
que nous avons fait une façon très
humble aujourd'hui à rambouillet mais
avec aussi beaucoup de force
oui c'est de l'émotion mais de l'eau
mais l'émotion combattante et avec toute
la force qu'il nous unis ont lavé
aujourd'hui haranguer nous entre en
résistance pour que nos libertés soient
sauvés je suis abdel qader j'en suis
fier mais ma république est fière aussi
d'avoir abdelkader à la tête d'une
circonscription telle que celle de
rambouillet chargé d'histoire changer de
toute l'histoire de la france c'est pas
une réaction en particulier à charlie
hebdo ça aurait pu être le canard ça
aurait pu être n'importe quel autre
journal c'est c'est la même chose on tue
la liberté d'expression charlie hebdo
était bien sûr réputé pour ses
caricatures les traits de crayon célèbre
de cabu charb et tant d'autres
leur mort a éveillé chez certains robots
lui tant d envie de prendre le crayon
j'ai eu envie de ses pages à veiller
j'ai un copain dans le photo club
bouchut qui avait fait faire un croquis
puis j'ai lu je suis mis devant le fait
de papier que j'ai pu j'ai laissé faire
le crayon pas d'où ça c'est clair
un moyen de
proto rendre hommage c'est un gain trop
grand mot mais j'ai eu envie de faire je
les fais dans cette marche républicaine
se côtoyaient toutes les générations et
même les citoyens de demain
une occasion pour certains parents de
partager leurs valeurs
la semaine a été très difficile avant
tout pour nous et aussi pour eux c'était
un choc pour toute la famille on leur a
transmis
voilà qu'est ce qu'on a ressenti nous
mais et on a été touchés droite au coeur
voilà on a pu leur transmettre ce que ce
en quoi on croit et ce en quoi on pense
dix mille personnes ont défilé à
rambouillet s'ajoutant ainsi aux près de
4 millions de français qui se sont
rassemblés un peu partout dans le pays
faisant de cette journée un événement
historique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
86 grand prix de formule 1 huit podiums
dont le mythique succès à monaco en 1972
sous une pluie battante pilote à l'aise
partout 11 fois champion de france de
moto 14 participations 24 heures du mans
jean pierre beltoise aime la compétition
par dessus tout et les qualités de
trajectoire jean pierre a été le premier
qui a redonné un certain lustre au sport
automobile français et qui a entraîné
dans la foulée d'abord une
revalorisation du sport automobile qui
était un peu tombé en désuétude en
france est une réussite qui inspire de
nombreux pilotes comme arnaud jabouille
ou encore prost après sa carrière il a
consacré la suite de sa vie à la
sécurité des pilotes
développe des stages de prévention
notamment au circuit qui portait son nom
à trappes avec sa méthode conduire juste
qui voulait ça m'intéresse pas du tout
de faire des circuits pour faire plaisir
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de faire des
chantiers pour qu'un jour le
gouvernement et les responsables des
boîtes 10 mais effectivement avec le
système mis au point par jean pierre
beltoise et conduire juste ont réduit de
moitié ou des deux tiers ou des trois
cas les accidents de la route très
proche de son personnel ici à trappes
parce que la plupart des gens qui ont
collaboré avec lui
l'on fait et le font depuis quasiment
l'origine c'est-à-dire pour la majorité
collaborateurs c'est plus de 20 ans jean
pierre beltoise est décédé à l'âge de 77
ans après deux accidents
cardiovasculaires à dakar
[Musique]